foreign
[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
the chair of John Lewis faces a
confidence vote as the business
considers radical ways to secure its
future
the travel Revival the world's biggest
tour operator Tui says bookings this
summer will be close to pre-pandemic
levels
the race to cut emissions a synthetic
fuel that can be used in existing
engines with no loss of performance
plus the open source rival to chat GPT
I'll be speaking with the chief
executive of databricks
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
heart of the city now the chair of the
John Lewis partnership Dame Sharon White
is facing a confidence vote by members
today as she fights to turn around the
Retailer's performance the partnership
which also owns the waitrose supermarket
chain posted a pre-tax loss of 234
million pounds last year and in March it
canceled its treasured staff bonus for
the second time in three years well Dave
Sharon has been looking into ways of
bringing more Capital into the
partnership to strengthen its position
including property deals and even
potentially selling a stake to outside
investors but that has sparked anger
among the Partnerships owners its
employees will joining me now to talk
about this is the sun's business editor
Ashley Armstrong Ashley welcome to you
this vote is the by the John Lewis
partnership Council now what is this
body yes so it's not the first time that
a chairman or chairwoman of John Lewis
has based at confidence very it's very
much kind of part of the employee-owned
principles of the mutual and actually
Charlie Mayfield Sharon White's
predecessor had two votes who won both
of those and actually his predecessor
Stuart hampson when he was thinking
about demutualization of John Lewis and
potentially floating it on the stock
exchange he also was facing some
rumbling on the council these Council
meetings are meant to be very Lively
debate that hold people to account but
the thing is is that Sharon White is
going into this in a very testy time as
you said you know it's rankled a lot of
John Lewis's employees about kind of
potentially bringing in an outside
investor it comes on the back of a 230
million loss 16 department store
closures and also this sense within the
partnership that what it was known for
customer service that very essence of
John Lewis seems to have been fading
because of all the cost cutting now
there are 61 members on this Council who
are they yeah well they're elected
themselves and and they all they all go
through this kind of special training
because
um there was this sense that they might
be over awed by kind of these board
meetings so they go through kind of a
due diligence setup and and they are
elected did officials I suppose kind of
from within different bits of waitrose
different bits of partnership and
they're meant to kind of represent the
whole of the kind of Retail Group yeah
so they are these are genuinely people
who work on the shops exactly and
exactly and what's interesting is um in
the previous votes that we had with
Charlie Mayfield as well when people
voted against it it wasn't almost like
that they disliked him it was like that
they wanted to have their faith restored
in the partnership it's a bit of a kind
of protest vote and um you know John
Lewis was very much at Payne's and it
has been at pains you know this isn't a
binding vote but I think it is still
symbolic in the same way that if MPS
vote for example for a Knighthood to be
stripped uh you know they don't have the
power to do that but it is sends a
message doesn't it yeah so it is
non-binding but the message is often
acted upon or is it um I mean so far
there hasn't really been kind of um a
chairman that's lost and I think that's
very very crucial it's kind of you know
where where Sharon comes out on this but
also I think you know there is this kind
of Reckoning within the partnership who
who is qualified to do this job because
John Lewis is an anasma to most other
British businesses and at one point it
was put on pedestal because of that
because of its employee model but you
know it's a bit like m s with uh
department stores and food but it's also
now trying to do lots of other things
with housing so who is qualified to run
John Lewis it's a very good question I
mean the point is here if if Dame Sharon
loses this confidence vote it doesn't
get away from the fact that this
business does need to raise more Capital
it can't borrow anymore so it's either
going to have to sell down assets like
Properties or potentially bringing
outside investors yeah and I think it is
really interesting that has been the the
thing that's been central question of
kind of what John Lewis does and it's
been okay so long as it's been the cash
machine but what we've seen and during
the pandemic and before that as its
store sales were declining and it didn't
move fast enough but online online is
actually really hard to make money out
of you know if people talk about it as
being the Silver Bullet For The High
Street but it's not at all
um so then how does it raise money it
can't it can't list on the stock
exchange it actually would require an
act of parliament to sell the business
and outside investor is definitely
something that Sharon White has had on
her cards since joining it has been kind
of mumbled around and talked about
um and at one stage she was even
considering a merger with marks and
Spencer in her early days and to be fair
that was kind of when marks and
Spencer's share price was in the
doldrums and probably slightly more
affordable now I think that's well off
the table Yeah she'd have been buying at
the bottom uh she'd done that wouldn't
she I mean you you raised a good point
there is there anyone actually that
could be doing a better job than Sharon
White well the thing that is lobbied at
her frequently and has been lobbied at
her since the start is that she is not a
retailer you know she came from ofcom
and actually she surrounded herself with
um Consultants you know kind of I mean
paper bricks who was brought in from the
co-op in a turnaround vector and she is
a now we've got a new chief executive
who you know is great in consumer but
still not a retailer I think actually
one thing that would be a really big
signal to the rest of the kind of
partnership employee base would be if
they got an out and out operator
retailer you know someone almost with a
cut and thrust of note knowing the price
and being able to walk through the sort
of food halls and department stores
knowing exactly how much everything
costs and having a real grip of it have
you got anyone in mind no as we as we as
we know there's a kind of you know sadly
a few characters that have been lost
from the retail space and probably maybe
for good reasons it's like you know we
want them we want them to be character
we want them to be a personality but
they also need to be modern now because
and they don't come cheap either and
they do not come cheap especially if
you're kind of looking abroad as well
absolutely Ashley good to see you this
morning thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and Compass Group hailed Strong's
growth in both Europe and North America
as it benefited from the return to the
workplace and a Revival in sporting
another life events the world's biggest
contract catering company reported an
operating profit of 1.05 billion pounds
for the six months to the end of March
on an underlying basis that was up 41 on
the same period a year ago will Compass
a major provider of meals at schools and
colleges around the world and employers
such as Google and shell said it would
in future be reporting in U.S dollars
rather than Sterling reflecting the fact
that two-thirds of its sales now come
from North America but it stressed it
had no plans to move its stock market
listing from London to New York the
shares are up four percent right now
Tui said this morning that bookings this
summer would be close to pre-pandemic
levels as it predicted significantly
higher operating profit this year the
world's biggest tour operator said the
bookings this summer were up 13 on last
year while summer 2023 bookings during
the last six weeks have been some six
percent ahead of 2019 levels well the
company reported an underlying loss of
42.9 million euros for the three months
to the end of March a quarter in which
it is traditionally lost making and that
was down from a loss of 123.1 million
euros a year ago
shares of J.D Weatherspoon have shot up
by more than seven percent this morning
after the pub operator predicted its
annual results will be at the top end of
City expectations Weatherspoon said it
sails in Easter week for the best in its
history with sales in The Current
financial year also likely to be a
record it said it's trading over the May
bank holiday weekend had been
exceptionally good including its busiest
ever Saturday but it said the coronation
weekend had been slightly less strong
like for like sales in the 13 weeks to
the end of April were up 9.1 percent on
the same period in 2019 prior to the
pandemic
and losses at Asos have widened as the
online fast fashion retailer ran up
exceptional costs related to its
reorganization the company reported a
pre-tax loss of 87.4 million pounds for
the six months to the end of February on
an adjusted basis well that compared
with a profit of 14.8 million pounds
during the same period a year ago and
larger reflected one-off costs of 203.5
million pounds including stock
write-offs and property impairments and
closure costs sales fell by seven
percent which Asos said reflected a
deliberate decision to reduce markdowns
and focus on more profitable sales it
said it was continuing to win market
share among key demographic groups such
as 16 to 35 year olds in the UK
and National Express is changing its
name to mobico group with effects from
next month the bus coach and rail
operator said the mobico name better
reflects the group's International
nature and its diverse range of Mobility
Services the national Express brand
first began appearing on coaches in
Britain 51 years ago as a name that
could be used by a number of state-owned
local bus companies that also operated
Coach Services or since its stock market
flotation 31 years ago it's Diversified
into other modes of Transport the
company stressed that the national
Express name will still be used on its
UK National coach network
foreign
[Music]
last night sell-off on Wall Street was
followed by declines overnight for
equities in most of the asia-pacific
region in fact Mumbai was the only
Market in the region not to finish lower
overnight well in Europe stocks are also
largely in negative territory this
morning there's the current picture all
the main Continental European indices in
negative territory right now talking
points this morning include credit
agricole France's second largest bank is
ahead some five percent in Paris on
better than expected quarterly results
well here in London the ftse 100 is also
a negative territory it's off nearly a
quarter of one percent the drug majors
are weighing on the index today there
are some gainers to mention then the
leading Blue Chip Gainer right now is
Melrose it's been up as much as seven
percent this morning on a trading update
which a Sky's Mark Kleinman reported
yesterday it has pledged to focus for
now as a focused aircraft engine group
Engineering Group in the same sector
Rolls-Royce is ahead by one and three
quarter percent on growing optimism
around Aviation outside the ftse the
annuities specialist just group is up
five and a half percent right now on
positive broker comment but Asos
mentioned them a moment ago they're off
some 12 and a half percent on those
results on the foreign exchange markets
well it's pretty quiet this morning
that's ahead of U.S inflation data out
later today Sterling more or less
unchanged against the dollar it's ahead
by a tenth of one percent or so against
the Euro The single currency meanwhile
off by a similar amount against the
Greenback as for the oil price well that
has fallen following an unexpected rise
in U.S crude inventories about a Brent
crude will currently cost you 76.26 a
barrel that is off one and a half
percent on the session joining me this
morning is Rachel winter she's a partner
of course at killer KidCo Rachel good to
see you this morning
um let's start with compass biggest of
the businesses reporting today and some
really really powerful results you might
say
yeah great results here so this is the
world's biggest catering company so they
provide food for offices schools
hospitals sporting venues and what they
found is their demand has been
particularly High because people are
returning to the office following a
lockdown they're finding that lots of
companies are wanting to offer their
employees free food to try and entice
them back to the offices and they're
also finding that because of problems
with inflation finding staff they're
finding that a lot of companies are now
wanting to Outsource the provision of
food rather than doing it themselves so
they really have done very well with new
business as well so all things
considered they have been able to
increase their outlook for the full year
yeah a really interesting point they
make in the statement their raged I
thought that there's still masses of
growth to go for lots of uh companies
and employers and indeed colleges and so
forth have yet to Outsource their
catering when they do that is a massive
opportunity for this business
it is absolutely I think this is a huge
market so the opportunity is massive and
it's also a very international business
so as you said earlier about 67 of their
revenues come from the US and I think
there's a lot more scope to grow there
so there really is a huge amount of
opportunity for this business
what did you think about the
announcement that they're going to be
reporting in dollars from now on I mean
presumably that means divis is going to
be paid in dollars as well makes it a
bit of a currency play for UK investors
it does I think it makes a lot of sense
I mean with two-thirds of their revenue
coming from the US I think it makes
sense to report in dollars I think the
problem that a lot of UK listed
companies have is that if they report in
Sterling and they earn lots of money in
dollars because the exchange rate can be
quite volatile that then makes their
profits look quite volatile so I think
it does make sense to report your
profits in the currency in which you're
earning most of your revenues
now what have you made of these numbers
from Tui today I mean we've often heard
it said that holidays are the last thing
consumers will give up when times are
tight I mean these this statement kind
of confirms it doesn't it
it does so I thought it was quite
interesting that prices are 26 higher
this summer in comparison to 2019 and
yet that doesn't seem to be stopping
people from booking so too it does seem
to be experiencing very strong demand
for holidays so I thought the update
looked quite positive but the shares are
down quite heavily today so I think
people are still quite concerned that
the company is still a loss making and
also too he still has quite a high level
of debt despite the right situ they
completed a couple of months ago so I
think those concerns are still Weighing
on investors I mean there really is a
sort of confident Buzz around Aviation
more broadly just now I mean we had that
Mammoth uh Blockbuster deal yesterday uh
Ryanair ordering 40 billion dollars
worth of aircraft from Boeing
yes absolutely massive so there does
seem to be a huge demand for going on
holiday and I think that's not
surprising given that we've had a couple
of years of lockdown people have been
prevented from going away and I think
there is a lot of pent-up demand
now what about wetherspoons numbers
again I mean consumer confidence is
supposed to be fairly shaky at the
moment not according to Weatherspoon
no great results here so they are
expecting this to be their best ever
year for Revenue they have said it's
thanks to a couple of very strong bank
holiday weekends and also the Easter
weekend so they have been taking in a
lot of money I think that's partly
because inflation is particularly high
for food and drink so that means that
the rate of sales for wetherspoons will
be higher because of that but I do also
think we have got clearly a cost of
living crisis at the moment and
wetherspians is a lower cost operator
and therefore I think it probably is
picking up some business from people
trading down
all right Rachel got to leave it there
good to see you this morning thank you
thank you
now it sounds almost too good to be true
producing synthetic fuel in a completely
fossil free process that can be dropped
straight into the existing engines of
cars aircraft commercial and
agricultural vehicles and with no loss
of performance and no need for engine
modifications well that's a claim of
zero petroleum a British startup which
has already demonstrated the fuels
Effectiveness in a test flight carried
out by the Raf in November 2021 I've
been speaking with Paddy low he's Zero's
founder and chief executive
or it's not really a trade secret it's
really exciting you just make fuel from
air and water
and that may sound extraordinary but
when you burn any kind of
petroleum fuel so gasoline petrol diesel
Jack fuel craft what comes out the
exhaust is burnt hydrocarbon so that's
carbon dioxide which we know is a
problem in the atmosphere and water
so all we're going to do is take those
exact emissions carbon dioxide and water
and turn them back into fuel it's it I
mean it's that simple but in another way
obviously not simple but it's chemistry
yeah I was going to say if it was simple
someone would have done it by now why
hasn't this been achieved earlier well
in in some essential forms it has been
done before there's a process called
Fischer trots which was invented a
hundred years ago in Germany so that
technology has been used for many years
to turn coal Coal gas
which was the old gas in our Network
into liquid fuels so so the essential
synthesis has been around a good while
but of course now it's coming into a new
lease of life with a new intent which is
to become free of fossil fuels and
fossil carbon the problem in the
atmosphere is not carbon it's a fossil
carbon and so in this process we're
circulating the same carbon from the
atmosphere not bringing new carbon out
of rocks which is the problem of global
warming so it's kind of a neutral I mean
in terms of the carbon output compared
with conventional fuels that there is
none this is just carbon being recycled
so it's exactly the same carbon out of
the exhaust pipe but because you used
carbon from the atmosphere to make that
fuel then it is completely neutral
and Incredibly exciting because if you
think into the future when you know
we're growing up now in a the end tail
end of the fossil fuel era
and there's a lot of guilt around that
with most people should be because of
the problems that that's causing with
imbalance and global warming but
um you know for me that's just a
transition to what will be indefinitely
sustainable with synthetic fuels and
there's a great endorsement of that if
you think I'm a crazy guy who just got
on the show
um synthetic fuels have just last week
been endorsed by the EU with a scheme
called refuel EU
refueling mandates synthetic fuels in
European Aviation
to some really high levels so up to 35
by 2050. so it's a known thing uh and we
we zero are one of the players in that
space that's now mandated by European
law and of course you've already proved
the uh technology works because you did
a pilot with the RAF more than 18 months
ago now yeah November 21 we flew a plane
or rather the chief test pilot the RAF
uh flew a plane an aircraft
um with only our synthetic fuel on board
um and that secured a Guinness World
Record I'm so very proud of that
and really that was a great
demonstration that this isn't just just
a paper idea this this is a reality you
can run real engines exactly the same
but on a carbon neutral fuel what sort
of Interest are you getting from for
example the car manufacturers
so car the car automotive sector has
been an interesting one because clearly
they've been aiming for all electric you
know again by mandate
um so it's not not a sector we've put a
lot of attention to but again again the
EU you may have seen just consist uh
allowance of e-fuels e-fuel is another
name for a synthetic fuel in Europe to
continue manufacturing ice internal
combustion engine cars Beyond 2035
provided they use synthetic fuels so
Automotive sector is again in scope for
us although
we would say it's not not our primary
focus because uh you know electric cars
are also a very good solution in that
sector
but but most other sectors Aviation
agriculture Marine General Industry any
anything mobile that has to carry a lot
of weight or endurance
um synthetic fuels are actually uh
often the best answer and very often the
only answer to to de-fossilize the
process and what about the manufacturing
infrastructure obviously producing
conventional fossil fuels that power
aircraft and and cars it requires vast
refineries presumably something similar
is involved here is it it is a capital
intensive industry because you have to
build a machine that makes the fuel
um but in another way it completely
changes the Paradigm so we're you know
we we're used to all oil companies or
people that go and find oil in really
difficult places that get more and more
difficult every year
um the the great thing about synthetic
fuels and it really is a new paradigm
is that you you build a machine you can
own it and make your own oil in effect
in your own backyard so that brings all
sorts of different thoughts you know
energy security price security
um back you know no need for a long
distance transport you know pollution in
in marine pollution uh but but mainly
about that security you know you own a
machine you make your own fuel it is not
something that's possible today in the
fossil fuel sector
I was Paddy low from zero petroleum well
still to come here on inking live we're
going to be speaking with the chief
executive of the data processing and
analytics platform databricks about its
rival to chat GPT stay tuned
[Music]
and they are overwhelmed just like we
are and they're the thought that they
might have more and more work coming
their way
um is something that doesn't fill them
with tremendous excitement
um I think there are some things that
can be dealt with very easily on the
telephone I think uncomplicated urinary
tract infections in women uh is is the
perfect telephone consultation and it
doesn't need a pharmacist or a GP that
can be done very easily and
straightforwardly so I think the message
is very mixed as far as we're concerned
and it all comes back to this whole
issue about capacity doesn't it we are
overwhelmed uh General practices
overwhelmed my Pharmacy colleagues are
overwhelmed they remember the terrible
times during covert when really they
were the only open face-to-face clinics
uh around because we were all shut not
seeing patients face to face so they do
an amazing job and yet I gather that
hundreds of them are closing each year
because they can't make ends meet I can
tell you that in our first half hour of
opening this morning we took 174 calls
at one stage 45 people were waiting to
see us I'm pleased to say that we've got
the call queue down to 15 now 250 calls
in
um but it is hard work doing this and
yes digital phone calls are very good at
producing a queue but you've still got
to provide the stuff that patients need
once they've made the phone call at the
moment it's the average 10-minute
consultation is an impossibility uh a
very droll GP in one of our Rags
actually worked out that you could
actually spend an hour and a half
talking to somebody about something not
very complicated
um every patient that comes to see me I
think is thinking that's the last time
they'll ever go and see me and so
they're they're planning for the rest of
their lives so consultations are very
long and very complex and then the
demand is so huge so we have a huge
capacity issue
[Music]
welcome back now interesting artificial
intelligence has mushroomed since the
recent launch of chat GPT but some
companies have been active in the field
for quite some time one of them is
databricks a data processing and
analytics platform that uses AI which
was founded a decade ago it recently
launched Dolly 2.0 named after the Clone
sheep Dolly which is its own open source
rival to chat GPT will join him in as
Ali Godsey he's the chief executive of
data bricks Ali good to see you this
morning you launched Dolly 2.0 only
weeks after the launch of Dolly 1.0 why
why the haste well I mean the space is
moving so fast and there are new results
every week Frankly Speaking so uh you
know it's just it's just a piece of
things right now actually I I follow
this stuff on a daily basis now and what
uh without getting too technical on me
what are the main differences between
Dolly 2.0 and Chachi PT yeah actually
there's so many of these released out
there but you can't actually
commercially use them and the reason is
most of these models have been trained
using output that comes from chatgpt and
the terms of license of chat GPT says
you cannot use its output to create
something that competes with it that's
against its terms so Dolly 2 is the
first model ever that's actually you can
speak to it and they can do those kind
of things and it's commercially usable
it it's not tainted it's not using any
open AI output at all and the key thing
is it's open source yes it's open source
you can verify you know what was it
trained on what does it do you can
really understand it which you can't do
with these models that for instance
openai provides because they're behind
an API you don't have access to the
model you don't know what's there all
you can do is ask questions and see if
you like the answers or not but you can
actually look inside and see what's
under the hood just the fact that it's
open source potentially mean it's more
open to misuse well I think it also more
open to researchers understanding it and
training new versions of it that is
better aligned to what we humans want so
that you know it is more honest it is
more helpful and that you know it's
harmless I mean some people say that
this is the issue with chat gpts almost
goes out of its way not to offend is
there a danger that Dolly might offend
some people with its answers yeah but
you know it's a research vehicle that we
can use right it's dolly is not
something that we put out there that
anyone can go use and chat with right so
it's more for Enterprises to figure out
for their use cases that they have they
can train Dolly to do specific tasks
that they need for their companies right
so it's more intended for businesses
than for consumers and I think you're
going to be licensing it added around a
hundred dollars a throw is that right
yeah it's you can train it with less
than 100 yes and a few hours how many
licenses will you need to sell them for
it to pay for itself
well we didn't spend much actually
effort to build it so yeah it's actually
it's kind of already paid for itself
okay right what sort of take-up have you
had thus far it's and so many people are
using it we didn't actually know we
didn't know that it would have such
uptake but all kinds of use cases that
we couldn't even imagine you know people
are using it to read electronic medical
records to understand diseases right
people are using it to read insurance
documents to understand risk people are
using it to translate you know press
releases to 80 languages in just one
shot and so on things like that so there
are a lot of interesting use cases I
mean this is the the thing about AI is
we're it's almost pushing at things that
we don't properly understand I mean
that's that's a concern that's often
raised about it yes you know so I think
I actually welcome if we look we look at
things like euai act and so on uh I
think these are early days definitely
this kind of Technology will change the
world do great things I think actually
it's going to revolutionize Healthcare I
think we're going to be able to solve
all kinds of diseases and cure them I
think it's going to be amazing for
Education we're going to be able to
everyone will have their own Professor
you know that can help them understand
learn any subject they want I think
actually scientific breakthrough will uh
be amazed you know we'll we'll have
great things happening there but people
can also use it for bad things you know
bad use cases you know it's technology
that makes anyone more effective so
people who want to do great things they
can do it much more effectively people
who want to do bad things they can also
do it more effectively so we need to
regulate it of course of course but I
mean yeah there is this in uh Hogarth in
the Ft Road a couple of weeks ago he was
talking about god-like AI that
potentially threatens the whole of the
human race is that overregging it yeah
so I think there's two separate problems
and they get confused so one is this
kind of like god-like AI that takes over
everything Skynet and so on I don't
think that's a big risk okay of course
it's scary but it's not a big risk
because we're nowhere close to building
anything that's like that we just have a
parrot that repeats back what it's seen
by compressing all of the web so it's a
very good smart parrot with great memory
and it can combine things and synthesize
them but it's not like a human so I
don't I'm not too worried about that
problem but the existing technology that
we actually have built itself could be
used you know like if you want to create
spam and things like that so there are
high risk use cases and those are the
ones that are being actually regulated
for instance by the by the uai acts and
I think that's good and what about this
bonfire of like college opposite it's
going to lead to
exaggerated well I think many jobs will
change I think we still want a human in
the loop you know do you want to go to
the doctors and just talk to a robot
that just tells you that you know we're
gonna chop your arm off like you know
you want to have a human there that
explains it do you want to send your
kids to school with just robots uh no of
course we want the human teacher there
so I think we still want you in the loop
if you look at for instance you know in
an airplane we have autopilot but would
you want to fly a plane that has no
pilots in it right so we still want the
human in the loop and I think the human
will still be there as a guardrail and I
think this nature of jobs will change
and there'll be new jobs that pop up
that don't exist today we don't know
exactly what they are so I think they
will create also jobs but yes it's going
to change the nature of existing jobs
what did you make of this call from some
tech leaders including Elon Musk
recently to pause AI development for six
months well he said can you please pause
this I'm building my own for six months
so that that sounds like a smart idea
but six months is not going to really
change anything and it's since this is
all out in the open the gene is out
researchers all over the planet are
working on it so you know this six month
moratorium doesn't really change
anything so I I don't think it actually
affects anything now since we had you on
the program last a couple of years ago
you completed another funding round in
August 2021 that valued you at 38
billion dollars would you be valued at
that some if you were doing another race
today well no one really knows right
until you go out and do that but there's
a lot of excitement around Ai and I
think the things that you could do with
databricks you can now do even more
effectively using these large language
models so I think the use cases have
actually you know exploded for for our
technology and companies are coming to
us so every CEO I know is asking what
does this mean for my company what
should I do about it tell me the
strategy how do I you know can we please
sit down uh so I think it's going to be
great for our business I don't know
exactly what value I would put on it um
do you need to raise Capital anytime
soon not really I mean you know we
raised I mean two and a half billion
dollars in a short period of time so we
still have most of that capital and
we're fully funded plenty to go Ali I
could talk to you all day sir but we're
going to leave it there good see you
this morning thank you
still to come here only King live why
Citroen is targeting the Indian market
to drive growth outside Europe don't go
away
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back now supply chain challenges
docked both the manufacturing and sale
of new cars in Britain last year new car
registrations during 2022 were down two
percent on 2021 with sales of petrol
cars down by 10 in diesel by 39 in the
first four months of this year though
new car registrations have been solidly
higher it was to this backdrop that
virtue motors which also trades under
the Bristol Street Motors and Macklin
Motors brands today announced an
adjusted pre-tax profit of 39.3 million
pounds for the year to the end of
February that was down from 80.7 million
pounds the previous year reflected a big
increase in costs sales were up by 11 to
a record four billion pounds of share
prices currently ahead by some three
percent will joining me now as the chief
executive of virtue Motors Robert
Forrester Robert welcome to you um just
before we talk about the the business in
more detail just talk to me about the
headline um profit number if you would
please well why why did it drop at the
headline level
uh well last year was a completely
exceptional year for the motor retail
sector we saw a massive increase in used
car values when you're sitting on 170
million pounds of used car stock uh the
margins on used cars went up that was
always going to be an extraordinary year
because this is actually our our second
highest profit that we've ever made and
if you took that year at that last year
out it would be a record year so we're
delighted with the numbers this year
good good now what about uh in car price
inflation right now I mean I see from
the smmt today they're still talking
about uh significant used car inflation
yeah I think used cars have stabilized
if I'm honest
um there's small growth but we're
probably our average sales price is
around 2 000 pounds higher than it was
this time last year but we're not seeing
the explosions we saw last year it's
broadly stable now and I would imagine
would get back to something like
normality over the next 18 months where
used car prices monthly months would
actually drift down in normal times and
what about new cars what are you seeing
there
uh well as you said in your Preamble uh
we've seen an increase in the new car
market for about the last nine months
the semiconductor issues Logistics
issues are being worked through the smmt
uh which is the manufacturers increase
their forecast for 2023 to 1.83 million
Which is higher than 2022 but a long way
down from the the Halcyon date of a 2.3
million even at 2.6 million market so
we're still in a quite a constrained uh
Supply position
now what about the competitive about
drop a lot of your the New Kids on the
Block these online guys like kazoo are
having to rein in their Ambitions what
do you take away from that
I take away what was obvious from the
start which is pure online retailing of
cars is a very very minor item we've
actually been doing it in our business
since May 2017 and we sell on average 8
000 used cars a month of which about a
hundred are so purely online people want
to touch and feel they want to see a
used car make sure it suits them and the
number of people who actually want to do
a pure online transaction with nobody
talking to them it's minimal and this is
a reflection of reality and what's
happened to the online disruptors
now being acquisitive is in the DNA of
your group you completed the acquisition
recently of Helston garages how's that
Trading
uh it's training really well uh We've we
bought it in mid-December in January
we've sent lots of people down to the
South West we've rebranded the
businesses got all our systems and
processes in and and the business has
traded really well so we're delighted
with that we could probably do some more
growth and Acquisitions in the coming
months on the back of on the back of
that success
what sort of things are you looking for
in acquisition targets right now
well we are a franchise business so we
work very closely with the manufacturers
and then actually they work with us in
binding our areas for growth uh we have
to get permission to manufacturers to
buy businesses so the manufacturers are
working with us on identifying targets
uh we as you said we've bought nearly
200 dealerships in in 15 16 years so
people do contact us if they want to
sell their business and and then we'll
look at it you mentioned uh just now you
rebranded uh hellston you don't always
read I mean obviously uh Bristol Street
which is a very very old brand you're
doing some rather lovely advertising
around it at the moment uh What uh goes
into considering whether you hold on to
a brand name or not
well Bristol Street Motors in England
and Wales is the the
is the brand actually has more awareness
in the general public it's been around
for 100 years uh We've grown it quite
substantially so it's a very nice brand
and as you said the advertising goes
into that history uh around actually the
West Midlands in particular so we won't
that's yeah it's got 54 property brand
awareness it's it's a fantastic brand
the Matalan brand in Scotland is
specifically for Scotland and I think
that works and then for our premium
franchises uh We've grown The Virtue
brand and we do a lot of sports uh
sponsorship marketing football rugby
basketball cricket and we are suddenly
growing awareness of that brand and we I
think we've got 80 dealerships now onto
the virtue brand nowhere you work with
most of the world's major car
manufacturers they're ready in this
country where you'd really be looking
actively to grow market share
yeah I mean we've grown substantially
actually with Toyota last couple of
years uh we've got somewhere where we're
underweight we clearly look at the
manufacturers and assess you know have
they got the financial Firepower to
invest in electrification uh you know
what are their strategies but we
represent more brands that manufacturing
Brands actually anybody else in the
United Kingdom we've got good
relationships with them and we're happy
expanding we do all of them
all right Robert we've got to leave it
there I'm afraid good to talk to you
this morning I know results stays very
busy appreciate it thank you bye-bye
now we're going to stay with cars
because the French car maker Citroen has
set itself a target of achieving 30 of
its sales from outside its European
homic Land by 2025. to that end Citron
which is part of stalantis is targeting
India as one of its biggest growth
markets and that was why it shows New
Delhi as the location for the launch of
its newest model the C3 aircross SUV
I've been speaking with citroen's new
chief executive Thierry koskas
India is first a growing Market we think
that very soon the market will reach 5
million units and on top of that Citron
is a new brand in the market we
introduced the brand in 2019 uh we have
a strategy with one new model every year
we started last year with a hatchback C3
this year today with the new C3 across a
brand new SUV next year where there will
be a fair model all the three models
have been designed built and uh
engineered in in India so it's really a
new opportunity and a new frontier for
the Citroen brother and why have you
chosen the C3 aircross as being the
spearhead for this assault on the Indian
market well you know the Indian market
is has a great appetite for SUV mid-size
SUV this vehicle was completely designed
and engineer other in India actually
that's a world premiere this vehicle is
presented today in India and also in
Latin America and all the car has been
designed and adapted to the Indian taste
and the requirements of the the market
we are here in the heart of the market
midsize SUV that's more than 10 percent
of the Indian market and that's where we
want to be and will that be all electric
versions of this available
at the moment we go for a petrol version
because this is what sells in India no
decision for electric but you know that
the previous model the C3 the first
model we introduced uh in India uh has
been electrified actually six month
afterwards in the car we introduced the
all-electric version that we sold at the
beginning of the year with great success
we think that uh electric cars has a
great feature in India because it very
much fits the usage of the cars on Urban
and suburban area that's why we wanted
to be one of the first manufacturers in
this market which we did with C3 so uh
no plan for C3 across but not come it's
quite a crowded segments of the market
you're up against the likes of the
Volkswagen Golf the Toyota Corolla the
Renault Megan what will give you the
edge do you think in the uh SUV Market
in India they are a very strong company
of what makes the offer unique is we
have an SUV with all the DNA of the
Citroen brand particularly when you see
the car ruminess and comfort are
absolutely unmatched in the segment one
of the key features that we are also
offering is we have a five-seater
version and a seven seater version which
is unique in the segment so we will be
the only ones to offer such a feature
now your European sales last year fell
by around 16 are you optimistic that you
can turn that around relatively quickly
yes we want to turn that around as
quickly as 2023 uh the Citron brand
deserves a much better position in uh in
Europe we have started to re-mobilize
our Network in all the countries I can
tell you that the first results are
there we are progressing in our home
Market in France in other markets as
well we have great offers we have a very
fresh lineup with electric cars with
petrol cars and we think that we can
very soon go back to the position that
the Citroen brand deserves in Europe
what have you made of attempts by some
countries particularly Germany to get
the EU to water down their their targets
on electrification well we are obviously
heavily pushing the uh electric cars in
uh all all Europe particularly uh one of
the flagship we have on the electric
Market is our ec4 that is a core
hatchback in the middle of the of the
segment we are heavily pushing that we
also offer electric vans which are so
important particularly for the German
market so we have an electric strategy
that is very bold and that is very
promising in the European market and how
about the supply chain issues with which
all car makers were grappling over the
last couple of years are those starting
to make life easier for you now
well we had obviously in the past year
uh many uh crises to face uh supply
chain issue particularly on
semiconductors what we can see is that
there is an improvement in the first
part of the Year 2023 uh situation will
further improve in the second part of
the year we aim that most of the crises
will be behind us by the end of 2023
foreign
[Music]
look at this morning's business pages
and the financial times leads its print
edition with a report that the
compensation bill for those affected by
the NHS contaminated blood Scandal could
reach 10 billion pounds it also reports
on its front page that big airlines are
having to invest heavily on cabins and
lounges amid a boom in demand from
Leisure Travelers for first class and
business class flights but the times
leads its business pages with a report
on the Blockbuster 40 billion dollar
order placed with Boeing Yesterday by
Ryanair for up to 300 new short haul 737
Max 10 Jets the times also reports on
its business front page a warning from
the Investment Bank Goldman Sachs that
European gas prices could rise in the
second half of this year and nearly
treble from present levels in the winter
there's also a very in-depth piece in
the times this morning on the woes of
purplebricks which we touched on in this
program yesterday meanwhile The Daily
Telegraph leads its business pages with
a report that banking startups and
Building Society is risk being forced to
set aside hundreds of millions of pounds
of customers money under plans to Shield
taxpayers if there is a new financial
crisis that's uh according to the
telegraph uh looking at something under
consideration apparently by the bank of
England the telegraph also reports
fascinating story this that Ireland is
to set up a sovereign wealth fund using
the proceeds of corporate tax receipts
which have been swollen by its ultra low
corporate tax rates that have attracted
Global Giants such as apple and alphabet
the parent of course of Google
no time for a pay-per-view reviewer
today I'm afraid but a reminder for you
to check out the Ian King live podcast
you can find that by scanning the QR
code on your screen right now it's
available now wherever you get your
podcast including the Sky News app Apple
and Google podcasts and of course
Spotify
well still to come here onion King live
Esports fans prepare for the first major
fortnite tournament here in the UK don't
go away
foreign
[Music]
they are overwhelmed just like we are
and they're the thought that they might
have more and more work coming their way
um is something that doesn't fill them
with tremendous excitement
um I think there are some things that
can be dealt with very easily on the
telephone I think uncomplicated urinary
tract infections in women uh is is the
perfect telephone consultation and it
doesn't need a pharmacist or a GP that
can be done very easily and
straightforwardly so I think the message
is very mixed as far as we're concerned
and it all comes back to this whole
issue about capacity doesn't it we are
overwhelmed uh General practices
overwhelmed my Pharmacy colleagues are
overwhelmed they remember the terrible
times during covert when really they
were the only open face-to-face clinics
uh around because we were all shut not
seeing patients face to face so they do
an amazing job and yet I gather that
hundreds of them are closing each year
because they just can't make ends meet I
can tell you that in our first half hour
of opening this morning we took 174
calls at one stage 45 people were
waiting to see us I'm pleased to say
that we've got the call queue down to 15
now 250 calls in
um but it is hard work doing this and
yes digital phone calls are very good at
producing a queue but you've still got
to provide the stuff that patients need
once they've made the phone call at the
moment it's the average 10-minute
consultation is an impossibility uh a
very droll GP in one of our Rags
actually worked out that you could
actually spend an hour and a half
talking to somebody about something not
very complicated
um every patient that comes to see me I
think is thinking that's the last time
they'll ever go and see me and so
they're they're planning for the rest of
their lives so consultations are very
long and very complex and then the
demand is so huge so we have a huge
capacity issue
thank you
[Music]
foreign
made local invest in your future Sky
News Financial reports sponsored by
interactive investor
[Music]
thank you
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back now in just over a month
from now the popular video game fortnite
will be staging its first major
tournament in the UK the McEwen Hall in
Edinburgh will be playing host to
Leading Esports stars from France
Denmark Serbia Canada Norway and the UK
competing for a 100 000 pound prize pool
in front of a live audience and many
more people will be watching on
streaming platforms such as twitch and
YouTube the event is called Red Bull
contested and it's sponsored by the
energy drink or joining me now is the
sports director for Red Bull contested
Reno mamitage Reno very good morning to
you um why hasn't there been a major
fortnights contest in the UK before now
good morning again thanks for having me
um I think there's been a lot of support
nights events around the world lately
and it has just emerged also due to
covet there has been a absence of
offline and land events and now uh with
the change in the scene and uh offline
events coming back I think this is a
great time and opportunity to have the
first big major offline line with the
Red Bull contested in Edinburgh and how
big will this be compared with other
Fortnight related events like the
fortnite World Cup
in terms of the players it's definitely
one of the highest competitions that
we've seen in a long time it's 100 of
the best players from around the world
will be competing uh we've invited
players from all across the world to
come to participate the prize pool is
100 000 pounds for this one so it's a
bit smaller price pool wise but I think
the competition and the level is
definitely higher also the game has
emerged a lot of the past five years so
it's going to be a more mature
tournament than it was before and you
are also offering some wild card places
how many of those are available
I think there will right now we're doing
the final invitations I think it will be
between 10 to 20 that's our hope this is
going to be uh qualifiers for that and
I'm looking forward to seeing who will
be able to qualify from the UK why do
you think the popularity and takeoff of
Esports in the UK has been slower than
in some other countries
I think we have had the same issue here
in Norway we've been kind of behind the
rest of the world uh following up and
the and the global emerging soft Esports
as it came Esports has been around for
over 20 years now it started in South
Korea and the United States and I think
UK has picked up significantly
especially in the last five years and
now since discovered we've seen some
major events Red Bull contested is one
of them we've also seen events like Red
Bull home grounds which is a major Valor
event valarint event we also have a
tournament going on right now in the UK
in London at the Copper box Arena which
is the mid-season Invitational League of
Legends so I think uh it's it's growing
very fast even though it's been a bit
slow to pick up I think it's it's also a
great time to get into Esports right now
you're also seeing lots of major teams
in the UK who've come to the scene in
the last years and lots of famous people
footballers who have been a part of that
so
I think the timing is good right now and
yeah I look forward to seeing the the
emergence of the UK scene absolutely I
think you've got some of the Manchester
City Esports team playing in fact in
this tournament
we do indeed as a Manchester City fan
I'm very happy to have them there it's
going to be really good we also have
other other players from other famous
teams from all across the world so it's
going to be an absolutely fantastic
tournament
s and what made you choose edinburgh's
the venue
I think Red Bull has been working a lot
to make this the best possible
experience for the players this was all
about the players when they came to me
and approached me to be a sports
director for this one they said hey we
want to have an authentic and cool
experience we want to do something
unique in in Red Bull style and um I
think the venue just came off as
something very uh untraditional for
fortnite traditionally when you see
Esports events it's a very like modern
Arena and mceven Hall is absolutely uh
different than that and it's a fantastic
value that I think is going to give a
completely different Flair to the
fortnite scene and I think the mix of
those two world is going to be very
interesting and make it a very cool
tournament for the spectators
and for people who
don't necessarily know about fortnite
does it require a different
video games I mean if I'm very good at
FIFA does it automatically follow or be
good at fortnight
not necessarily I'm a FIFA Player myself
I'm not that great at fortnite even
though I was leading the become Legends
one of the top Global teams who won the
last Global Championship but I think uh
fortnite is a way harder mechanical game
it has an easy accessibility so anybody
can jump in and start playing it but I
think it's very hard to master it's a
very complex game with lots of different
mechanics like building which you don't
have in FIFA obviously so it might take
a few rounds but now it's becoming more
and more accessible there are several
game modes that are open up for
beginners like you and and me who make
make it more easy to uh places
definitely a good game to get started on
it looks as though I mean looking at the
profiles of some of the players that
you've got the top players in this
competition they all seem to be more or
less exactly the same age they're all
around 1920.
yeah definitely I think like fortnite is
the first uh game to kind of opened up
Esports to Global audience in a way
where it has an accessible and open uh
landscape traditionally Esports has been
kind of a bit of a closed off like it
has a very strict like from the
Grassroots to the top level and fortnite
when epic games came with fortnite they
were like okay we're just gonna have a
completely open ecosystem where
everybody can compete and I think a lot
I think fortnite is also the first
esport that many young players are
playing so it kind of they started when
they were young and then they progressed
as they
um grew up and I think it's it's
fantastic to see that openness and that
open attitude that epic games has had to
fortnite I think that has made it very
accessible as an esport that's why we
have these young talents who've now been
playing for the last three four five
years since fortnite came out in 2017 so
I think that's one of the reasons and
how the ticket's selling
um I'm not sure I hope it's good I
really look forward to it so uh hoping
to get the place packed uh either way I
think it's going to be a sick experience
for everybody in the crowd this is going
to be a great experience for people on
Twitch and tuning in from all around the
world so I look forward to it all right
now good leave it there appreciate you
joining me today thank you
thank you so much Ian have a good day
that's it from me I'm back at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning hope to see you then in
the meantime do stay tuned after this
short break Jane sucker is up with all
the build up for prime minister's
questions thanks for joining me today
cheerio
[Music]